also breaking here at five o'clock a man
telling police to shoot him before
opening fire at officers that's how
metro describes the scene of a recent
officer-involved shooting the suspect
killed by police on tuesday eight news
now reporter sasha loftus was at a press
conference today where we learned a lot
more about exactly what happened sasha
denise officers say this started as an
argument between two men but escalated
to something much more dangerous very
quickly downtown
mr leach's reckless and dangerous
actions not only endangered the lives of
the officers but the lives of citizens
who live in the neighborhood
the metro officers say once they got the
call about that argument and approached
the two men the suspect trent leach ran
away he then barricaded himself in a
vacant building and fired 20 rounds at
officers with a semi-automatic weapon he
pointed his gun directly at police so
swat officer adam fired one round at the
suspect killing him police say leach
does have a criminal history but did not
disclose any further details the other
man involved in the initial fight was
hurt police say he is expected to be ok
and does not face any charges tonight
reporting live at metro headquarters
sasha loftis live local now